Venezuelans voted overwhelmingly in
favor of their country's claim to Annex
a large SWAT of neighboring oil Rich
Guyana in a non-binding referendum on
Sunday but despite a major campaign by
the government of Nicolas Maduro to
promote the vote as an act of patriotism
and assurances of a massive
participation the turnout appeared to be
low at many polling places forcing
authorities to extend the vote by 2
hours where
we were hoping to see more people voting
by this time especially since this is a
cause we should all care about
regardless of political
color the referendum asked whether
citizens favored establishing a new
Venezuelan state in a long disputed
territory known as the Eko a region that
has been part of Guyana for more than a
century Venezuela has tried to reclaim
it since the
1960s the recent discovery of large
deposits of crude oil has heightened
tensions president Nicolas Maduro
labeled the vote a
success we are solving through
constitutional peaceful and Democratic
means an imperial dispossession of 150
years on Friday the un's international
court of justice that has jurisdiction
on the case ordered Venezuela not to
take any actions that could affect
guyana's sovereignty over the
region the Venezuela's aggressive
rhetoric and actions including moving
troops along the border has many guyan
on edge their president sought to
reassure them over the fear of an
invasion I want to assure gues that
there is nothing to fear over the next
uh number of hours days months ahead of
course our vigilance will be enhanced
but we are uh working around the clock
to ensure that our B remain intact and
the people and our country remains safe
many analysts believe the referendum is
mainly a ploy for Maduro to drum up
support ahead of next year's
presidential elections but if it is a
distraction tactic it's one that is
creating real worry across the region
Alexander RTI Al jazer